i'm the queen of the world
yes
i feel invincible like i have
superpowers or something
you hear that all you ask the world i
can do anything i want and no one can
stop me
he does talk like you're listening yeah
oh my gosh last time i was like who are
you you're
brilliant oh my god
that is the cutest effing puppy i've
ever seen my entire life oh my god i'm
just gonna take him and i just want to
bite his little ears off i just want to
take his little legs and just like snack
on him like little like like chicken
drummettes yeah i just want to take his
fuzzy little perfect head i want to put
it in my mouth and squeeze down on it
hard until i have a puppy face diamond
in my mouth i feel like i have to wrap
his face in a towel and then beat it
with a tire iron i'm going to buy that
dog i'm going to drive him to the vet
and i'm going to have him put down
immediately
oh my god you know what i'm gonna have
to do i'm gonna have to take that
scrubby little nose yeah and just kick
it i just have to i wouldn't
kick it until it comes off on my shoes
like little puppy snout slippers and i'm
gonna go to a party and it's like oh my
god where'd you get those slippers like
these these are my face slippers my
adorable dumb little pudding that's
exactly what i was going to say
oh my god i just want to take his head
i'm going to peel the skin off of his
skull i know where you're going i want
to just start throwing it up like pizza
dough until it's long flat and round and
i want to take it to a picnic and toss
it around like a frisbee and a puppy
face frisbee picnic let's get him yeah
so cute so cute
oh my god is it me or is it like totally
mosquitoey out here oh my god remember
this one it was so cute so cute
so i'm doing this like airline food diet
it's like all i eat and i've lost like
16 pounds oh my god amy i almost forgot
to tell you we got a new receptionist at
work ew no way yeah so i'm in the common
area alone minding my own business yeah
oh she said something to you she came up
to me and no joke she's like hi i'm
sandy i don't believe we've met yet oh
she said that to you
no amy i'm not even kidding you she's
crazy um yeah no like i'm scared like
crazy like get this [ __ ] away from me
she's psychopathically batshit crazy oh
my god that totally reminds me i have a
new neighbor ew yeah she comes over my
house she knocks on the door with like a
package under her arm um stalker match
um yeah and she looks me in the eye and
she says to me um excuse me i think the
postman dropped this package off at my
house by accident she said that to you
yeah crazy bad i mean like i'm gonna
have to move because this bitch's nut
burgers make looney tunes stand at the
foot of my bed with a knife crazy oh my
god that totally reminds me oh yeah you
remember that girl at starbucks the
crazy one no a different one she's new i
haven't met her yet well she's crazy
uh-huh she gives me my change and then
she's like thanks bye
she smiled at you like that how crazy is
that that's like that's like insane in
the membrane crazy like like this is the
membrane she's inside of it because
that's insane no like i'm not even
kidding you amy that's crazy like it
puts the lotion in the basket or else it
gets the hose again cray to the motherfu
cray yeah like if jay-z had a sister her
name would be cray hey
you ladies want to meet channing tatum
is he really in there seriously oh
tanning
tanning what are you doing in a van
you're effing crazy i don't see you
channing why are you hiding in here
shanny are you like in a little ball
it smells like mildew in here
is that a meat hut
guy the moment i saw you last night at
the club totally had to ask you out are
you kidding me like the moment oh yeah
that's so sweet
i was actually afraid that you were
gonna be like one of those high
maintenance chicks you know
what yeah oh yeah
i don't know island control freak or i
don't even know
that's so funny
is it funny it's funny nah i'm like i
totally just like to be just like easy
going yeah yeah i win i'll be here in
five minutes and we're just now getting
our menus
oh i'm sorry
don't be sorry
be better
right okay i'll be better that's your
job
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so yeah my philosophy is pretty much
like keep it chill
right yeah yeah you know what i like
about you no what it's like you're not
afraid to be like brainy and respectful
right thanks i really like your boobs
i think we really complement each other
well just did it right there and uh i
pretty much go with the flow right right
and what the
is wrong with you
[Music]
excuse me do i look like mad max to you
i'm sorry do i look like mel gibson with
a mullet
no not not at all does he look like a
feral child with a boomerang in his hand
no then why the is water a rare
commodity here it's not it's not i'm
just uh
i'm sorry i'm just really slammed you'll
know when you're slammed because your
nuts will be on the table and my fists
will be covered in your blood
[Music]
um
you were uh
like kind of harsh to that guy
oh him yeah no
i was a hostess at a restaurant
in the industry that's how we talk to
each other i'll show you hey oh god oh
hey
what do you see there
what's your water
down
down down boy
then you need okay i have other tables
that i have
what does that look like to you
yes there's a little lipstick on your
glasses but it mean it's yours this is
what i want you to do i want you to take
this glass in the back
i want you to break it
take the biggest shard you can find and
bring it to me
and i'm gonna slit your color
all right i'm just i'll get you another
one i'm gonna split your throat
and watch you bleed out
and i'm gonna shower in your blood all
right
i'll get another water well that would
be great thank you
but as i was saying like i just feel
like it's like do unto others
it was your lipstick on the glass
what the hell is that what are you doing
wait wait no no no no no
oh my god
this tell you no one's ever
talked to me like that in my life
you
have his back
who does that it was your lipstick on
the glass he's just a waiter
you know what take his side i hope you
have a very happy life together
what's going on right now
what do you do
[Music]
seriously vegan no
no
megan you left the jacket hey you left
your check hey
don't do it
i just hurt her feelings and then she
left her jacket at least i could do
something backward jack don't do it
she does not need it it's 87 degrees out
you know she doesn't need it in your
heart of hearts you know she doesn't
need that jacket don't do it
[Music]
i think she's gonna need a jacket she's
not gonna be vegan you need your jacket
though
seem like a nice guy
i'm going to the bathroom okay
excuse me
excuse me
quiet down excuse me
excuse me
and excuse me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
looking for my boyfriend
girl okay right i'm doing it right now
dude me again
andre vegan
i'm shushing you
andre
negan
andre megan andre vegan
andre megan andre negan andre megan
andre megan andre
why would you go back
siri call andre don't call me
[Music]
will you facetime me i'm not gonna do it
right now you wouldn't be able to see me
it's dark in here i know that i can't
find you i'm directly behind you turn
around okay i'm gonna turn around
you didn't need to announce it just do
it i'm right there
stop yelling at me
naked have you sustained a head injury
or had a stroke in the last 10 minutes
what do you mean by that we can
dude put your phone yep away yep omg did
you just hang up on me yes
i'm not talking you sir i'm talking to
my boyfriend it's me meegan
get out of here no you get out of here i
can go wherever i want i'm looking for
my boyfriend i'm jay
come on you can't be honest
get off me mr director he's not the
director can you shine this light on the
audience i want to see my boyfriend let
me see something ah
the light's in my eyes meeting you
projection booth
don't shush me
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
and
excuse me
i couldn't find the
bathroom you totally chillax i'm so
annoyed right now can you like not talk
to me for like a second like that'd be
great that'd be fine that'd be fine by
me
but oh my god are you serious this is
bull
what could possibly be the problem with
letting two more people in
check your girl bro
excuse me what did you say check your
girl uh-uh it doesn't work like that no
one checks me because i'm not luggage
okay so you can go
yourself
megan seriously two more people are
gonna come out in a couple of seconds
and then we can go in yeah
let me ask you a question what was it
like being in the green mile he wasn't
in the green mile and clearly wasn't in
that movie what does tom hanks's penis
feel like megan moreover how does it
feel when swarms of bees are coming out
of your face seriously i'm sorry second
favorite movie don't apologize for me
yeah this is nice this is nice you look
like common meets the incredible hulk
when you brought the frankincense to
baby jesus did they like make you stand
outside the barn because you were too
big or did they invite you in with all
the other animals don't flare your nose
without me
do you have any idea how impolite that
is he hasn't moved his nostrils
once since we got here i saw them move
they did not move me they flare megan
they [ __ ] did not move your nostrils
flared more than a survivor from a boat
accident
what he's not even looking in the eyes
okay you know what if you're just gonna
continue to be a little prick you're
gonna get your ass kicked don't touch
your me meegan
crazy [ __ ]
totally love my nails right now
so over everything right now over the
floor i'm over the sky i'm over you over
that [ __ ] back there you're a [ __ ]
naked seriously whatever
um
excuse me oh god hey
what did you say what the [ __ ]
did you just say
you guys come back here with your little
itty bitty
dicks
you best control your lady yep oh
control your lady no he doesn't control
me cause let me tell you something
i'm not a remote megan baby can we just
let this go no i'm talking to the
[ __ ] of anarchy right now yeah you
why don't you all gather yourselves and
why don't you just go and figure out a
way to on each other's leathery penis
hey [ __ ] you [ __ ]
ah
it's not even the plural of penis
yeah
i'm the queen of the world
yes
i feel invincible like i have
superpowers or something
you hear that all you ask for the world
i can do anything i want and no one can
stop me guess you don't have to fight
your own fights a crazy [ __ ]
oh boy
nothing can stop me
are you kidding me
no seriously you've got to come back in
the bar right now
i don't even
know claire yeah i'm sorry
you left her jacket yeah well why don't
you give it to your new fat uncle
girlfriend right i didn't even met her
yet whatever you left your jacket me
gabe oh throw it in a river why would i
do that i don't care i'm over it fine
good
me
[Applause]
get gay jacket though
seriously vegan
you start buying drinks for everybody as
soon as she comes over i mean who does
that you didn't come back to the bar
you're literally an [ __ ] how is that
possible i can't be an [ __ ] i got
arms and legs and a head where's my
jacket i have your jacket do you want it
no you know what eat it why would i do
that you know what i'm not following you
anymore fine
me didn't come back to the bar yeah
yeah
now be good
negan do you want your
jacket no
seriously come back to the bar
you go back to the bar i'm gonna throw
this jacket in the water oh nice that's
really nice what do you want me to do me
again damn kiss my butthole okay good
fine fine then i'm going i'm leaving
right now
god damn it
might
no
like seriously your jacket yeah but it's
your jacket though
[Music]
i have your
jacket
i'm over it
seriously me
[Music]
so what do you want to do tonight like i
was thinking maybe we could meet up with
amy and brad and like before that we
could go to angelo's and before that we
could like just go
i have something to say
i had to say it in person
because it's
it's like super important
okay
um
i know this is sudden
but look i've been thinking about this
for a while
[Music]
and i know this is something that needs
to happen
i'm breaking up with you
cool love it totally fine with that
really yeah
cause i thought
i was i was really worried that you're
gonna be like mad
mad
oh my god are you kidding me
no
of course i'm not mad people grow apart
it happens it's like part of life no i'm
totally fine like love it love it love
it
um
so
uh
um you know we had a good run
yeah
don't be a stranger yeah
can i just
can i ask why
why
yeah like what i was like i'm doing some
work on myself and like trying to grow
as a person so i really like appreciate
you know why
yeah um
okay yeah that's like
you know i think that you're kind of
like a controlling
person thank you thank you for that
that's nice thank you for that
cool no problem yeah
so you know what your problem is andre
what
you keep tabs on people
every little thing somebody does you
have to keep a tab of it
wait i i
i can't tell if you're angry or not i'm
not
i'm totally not angry
oh no i'm excited it's good it's just
like you said your piece
and i just think that i deserve the
human decency to say my peace right
right is that
is that not okay no no no it's
no of course of course
you're a controlling manipulative person
everyone says it i i don't think that i
am yes you are andre yes
okay now like you sound pretty i'm not
angry
i'm not angry i'm fine i love it i love
that you came to my house and you broke
up with me in my space and then when i
think about that every time i'm here
that's great that is so perfect for me
it's the best thing that's around here
where else was i supposed to do it
because you won't come to my house oh
here he is the puppet master is back but
i'm not i'm not no i'm not the puppet
you're doing this to me it's true you
won't come to my house at my apartment
it looks like two rats just in it every
day oh right like thank you for that i'm
a [ __ ] thank you i didn't know i didn't
say [ __ ] i didn't always say am i evil
or am i a [ __ ] no no you're not evil
vegan you're not why are you punishing
me i'm not i'm not punishing you i know
you broke up with me and i'm not
supposed to feel punished who thinks
like that
i don't know i can't i'm sorry i'm sorry
okay me again i i guess i didn't think
it through well it's like too late now i
mean we're dying no it's not too late
megan megan seriously i just i i i i had
a feeling
that i thought was true and clearly
clearly it wasn't true
i'm so confused like are you breaking up
with me are you not bringing up with me
megan i'm not breaking up with you okay
cool so what do you want to do tonight
like i want to hang out with amy and
brad but maybe before that we can go to
answer those
things
what just happened
[Music]
oh
[Music]